since you mentioned illiteracy from uh
what is it 150 years ago let me ask you
about affirmative action you wrote a
book on the topic titled for
discrimination race affirmative action
and the law
uh first what is affirmative action
and uh maybe we could talk about what
your view is on it today sure well
affirmative action
uh refers to racial affirmative action
because there's various sorts of
affirmative action you can have
affirmative action for veterans you can
have affirmative action for
um uh in-state residents let's suppose
you have a school you know the
University of you know blah blah blah
and we're gonna we're gonna We want to
reach uh we we're going to give a reach
out a a hand to boost help the people
who live within this state or we're
gonna have a boost for veterans we're
going to have a boost for you know for
women
uh we're gonna have a boost for men in
certain circumstances
well we're the the the the the the most
that the type of affirmative action that
gets most attention and that's worth
noting as well
there's lots of different sorts of
affirmative action but when you say
affirmative action the type of
affirmative action that immediately
people are thinking about is racial
affirmative it seems like a race is at
the core of this American experiment
though part of in every part of its uh
bingo culture Bingo you know why is it
that you know we again you know there's
various there's various
ways in which institutions reach out to
help various sectors of our population
why is it that this is the one that
generates all of the pulling out of hair
and gnashing of teeth we can put that to
the side for a moment
racial affirmative action refers to
efforts in which institutions
um uh uh uh you know reach out to
provide assistance
to racial minorities now the reaching
out has can can happen in different ways
um a light form of affirmative action
might be reaching out in terms of
recruiting making a special effort to
make sure that uh young people let's say
in racial minority neighborhoods know
about your college
you know that's you know recruitment
um
on the other hand uh racial affirmative
action might take more you know might
take a stronger form and might take the
form of saying okay we have a
competition
and um
uh we think that there will be too few
racial minority kids
who do well enough in this competition
to to be admitted to our school so what
we're going to do is we're going to uh
in various ways uh give a boost
to the minority kids
um if if it comes down to you have two
kids uh they both you know I don't know
have
you know 99 on the test
there's one place left we only have one
spot left two kids
uh one's a black kid one's a white kid
they both got 99 we're gonna give it to
the black kid
why well black kid all there is to it
the black kid we wanna you know maybe
and then our Theory you know maybe our
theory is that black people have been
done wrong in the United States and we
want our institution to contribute to
making amends that might be a theory
another theory might be
um you know uh we as a as we we think
that we'll have a more interesting
student body we'll have a better student
body a more you know better discussion
if they're more black kids on campus and
unless we make a special effort to bring
more black kids on campus uh you know
our our student body will be
overwhelmingly monoracial we'll just
have you know white kids a few Asian
kids a few Latino kids if they're no
black kids here I don't know you know
it'll be lacking an important aspect of
American life that some sort of you know
the so-called diversity story so anyway
there are various theories
some are grounded like I said in
reparative Justice
some might be granted in distributive
justice so for instance when people say
nowadays you know
um we want a cabinet we want a team we
want a student body that looks like
America that might be a distributive
justice theory for why you want
affirmative action unless we reach at US
unless we
reach out and give a boost to certain
groups
they won't be here
and we want a campus that looks like
America and we won't have a campus that
looks like America unless we give a
special boost to I don't know the Latino
kids unless we give a special boost to
Black applicants so reparative Justice
distributive justice or
third diversity we just want to have an
interesting student body and to have an
interesting student body we want you
know kids from a wide array of places we
think that that'll make for a better
campus more interesting campus those are
three justifications for all of which
however are justifications for
uh in a competition
giving a special boost to some people
based on their race so what's your sense
can you make the case for affirmative
action and can you make the case against
it yeah I can make the case for and I
can make the case against the case four
I won't spend much time on this like I
said there are three
they're three
Main justifications
um your audience should know that
one
the justification that actually led to
affirmative action
is a justification that you don't hear
about in the courts because the courts
have said that that justification
is insufficient so the real
justification behind affirmative action
was you know in the late 1960s in the
aftermath of the Civil Rights Revolution
and the aftermath of the Civil Rights
Movement there was a feeling that well
okay fine we're not discriminating
against black people anymore but black
people have been disadvantaged
by the Discrimination that has been put
upon them
and this discrimination that was put
has disabled them
and so they go into competitions
and it's unfair
yeah they score less well on the
standardized test but
you know surprise surprise what the heck
uh they went to schools in which they
got the leavings of the white folks you
know the white folks
gave the black folks the old textbooks
that's what the black kids read the
white kids read the newest textbooks on
and on and on so
reparative Justice we're going to try to
repair
the scars left by past racial Injustice
and we're gonna and so it's sort of an
effort to overcome the vestiges of past
misdeeds that was one justification for
affirmative action and frankly I think
that's the justification that has always
been the predominant justification
whether people owned up to it or not but
that's one justification
the distributive justice justification
is is there like I say you know people
we want an integrated America we want an
America that looks like America
um in that justification
legitimacy is sometimes mentioned so for
instance
uh people will say things like
well
you know if we're gonna in the armed
forces you can't have an armed forces in
which
the you know the sort of the the people
on the ground
are you have a lot of people on the
ground who are people of color but none
of the people calling the shots none of
the generals
none of the made you know kernels are
people of color no and then you know
the the the the the people on the ground
are not going to stand for that
so for purpose of legitimation
we need to for for purposes of buy-in we
need to have a situation in which
people get the sense that
even if they're sort of low down
they're still part of the story they're
part of the team
so that's part of the sort of
you know just you know I don't know
distributive justice notion do you think
that's power to that I mean do you think
this value there's correctness to that
kind of idea I think there's some
because for the application process for
different universities I think that
there's probably a driving narrative the
justification for for
well affirmative action I don't know
where we put Dei efforts because they
overlap but they're not perfectly uh
overlapping the reason that the school
so yeah as you know there is a case
it'll we'll know about it it'll be
announced sometime in the next month
uh well month month and a half
um is the case of the Supreme Court of
the United States in which the
affirmative action program at Harvard
and the affirmative action program at
the University of North Carolina are
being challenged most people think
including me that the Supreme Court of
the United States
is going to limit if not
totally
seek to abolish affirmative action so
this is a very burning issue
as things currently stand
uh my University and other universities
Embrace affirmative action on the third
ground the diversity ground and what
they say
is
we need affirmative action because
affirmative action uh is good for
pedagogical reasons
now frankly
do I think there's something to that I
think there's a little something to that
with respect to some subjects
uh I don't think that's what's really
going on for the most part I mean if
that's what's really going on why why
don't we have more foreign students
you know why why isn't there a greater
effort to bring in more foreign students
why isn't there a greater effort to
bring in more I don't know uh religious
fundamentalists why isn't there a
greater effort to bring in and you could
just name
various groups that are you know you
hardly ever see them on campus so you
don't think this kind of effort of
driving towards diversity is um
uh rigorous enough I think it's often
pretextual I think frankly the real
reason has to do with
the belief and I think it's a good
belief I associate myself with the
belief it's it's just that because of
the legal rules the authorities can't
say this belief out loud
but it's still the case that a lot of
Institutions want to
help American society overcome its
racial past
the real animating Force now this thing
about
you know we'll have better classroom
discussions uh you know some discussions
I mean you know with some subjects
yeah listen I'm you know I'm an
ignoramus when it comes to physics my
sense of it is however that uh if you're
talking about physics you're talking
about physics and frankly it doesn't
much matter in terms of mastering
physics what the demographics of that
classroom or like well you either know
physics or you don't the interesting
thing I've noticed since doing this
podcast is uh one way it does matter
it's really lonely when you do a thing
and you don't see somebody that looks
like you doing that thing okay and it's
such a seemingly stupid thing why does
it matter if there's another person that
looks like you in this very shallow
sense but it seems to matter to people
and when I talk to for example women on
this podcast a lot of women reach out
saying how inspiring that is that's
interesting right like I think we're
still human and we see people that look
like us
and uh this kind of narrow shallow
definition of diversity still matters
okay well you know I think I think
I think you've made a good point and
maybe so so let's go back to the physics
I mean let's suppose that
under one scenario there's a classroom
and a kid sticks his head in a black kid
sticks to set in the classroom and
doesn't see anybody else black there and
has to make a quick decision and says
yeah you know nah this ain't for me
versus they stick their head in the
classroom they see a smattering of other
black people in the classroom they say
Let Me Show me try this and then they
try it and it turns out damn it they're
you know Albert Einstein
so you know to that extent I can see you
know
under that scenario maybe it does matter
so you know I'll have to recalibrate
still those are the three those are the
three leading justifications for
affirmative action you ask me where do I
stand with respect to affirmative action
oh no before we get to that are there
criticisms are the answer is yes there
are criticisms of affirmative action
affirmative action
is a policy like you know any policy any
policy is going to have some downsides
to it and affirmative action is no
different does affirmative action have
some downsides yes it does have some
downsides what are they well let me
mention a couple one
um
stigma
stigma so if if you have an institution
that says that it
reaches out to give a boost to certain
people
on a racial basis
they're going to be
people who observe that
and who are going to be thinking to
themselves hmm
if so and so is here and they were given
a special boost
doesn't that mean that they were not as
proficient
as the other people who were here and
who did not have that boost
so if they are not as proficient that
means that they might not be as good
they might not be as up to Snuff
is that part of our affirmative action
world yes it's part of our affirmative
action world yes
I'm a professor at Harvard Law School
one of the subjects I teach is contracts
uh actually that's probably the subject
I most enjoy teaching I think I most
enjoy writing about
racial conflict and the legal system but
as far as teaching I most enjoy teaching
contracts well on that very first day
on the very first day
when I you know 80 students come they're
especially the first year students
they're you know nervous
I show up
I'm quite sure that there's some
students there
who are thinking
okay well
is this guy as good
as my other teachers because you know I
know that uh you know institutions like
Harvard have made a special effort to
bring in people like this guy Kennedy
is he is good
well I mean I'm sorry if you have an
affirmative action
regime
people are going to think that and are
they crazy to think that no they're not
crazy to think that would no that's a
perfectly
logical thing for somebody to think
does it does it have an effect on me as
the teacher
he actually does have an effect on me
sure
um I'm aware that some people are
thinking that it doesn't I'm not you
know it doesn't
it doesn't you know make me shaking my
boots
am I aware of it yeah I'm aware of it
does it have an effect yeah it probably
does have an effect it probably does it
probably
it probably
makes me
uh
uh it probably makes me
redouble my efforts
because I don't want anybody to think
justifiably
that I'm less able than my colleagues
so
you know it's one of it's funny when I
was growing up my father used to tell me
over and over again Randy
Ty tie you lose okay brother let me just
tell you that and he was telling me that
because when he was you know in in an
earlier time Tai Tai you lose
it was you know if it's even and there's
a choice to be made the white person is
going to get the benefit of the doubt
now under affirmative action
there's been a switcheroo
oftentimes it's the black person who
gets the benefit of the doubt but I'm
still in a situation yes
to avoid the stigmatization yeah that is
imposed by affirmative action but is
that stigma there yes it's there it is
there
um I'll tell you another way in which it
comes up from a student's point of view
I'll never forget this
it was in my second year Law School
it was in tax class
we had a very famous tax teacher
wonderful tax teacher on the very first
day of class
Professor bitker wonderful man wonderful
teacher Boris bitker
called on the very first person he
called on was a black student I remember
this as if it were yesterday called on a
black student and was a black woman
student
and I remember when he called on her I
remember
just
I felt
I I I felt as if the room got quieter
really I felt as if the room got quieter
and I know there was a real tenseness
Within Me
he didn't call on me because he was
going on somebody else was a black woman
student
and I felt
different
I felt as if I
was
uh
I felt as if I was somehow
uh at issue
I felt as if my place I felt as if my
status
was
you know some small degree
at issue
in the positive direction of the
negative just at issues at issue and so
now all of this is happening really
quickly he calls on the student
this is you know happening like in
seconds yeah and she responded and she
responded really strongly it was clear
she he asked her a question
she answered the question she answered
the question you know beautiful I mean
you know very strong comprehensive
wonderful response
now you might say okay well you know
smart student okay fine next
after class
after class I went up to her
and I clearly remember this I said
that was great
thank you
why
because I'm a black student
predominantly white institution Yale Law
School
and
I felt
some of the
again you know affirmative action
I felt
some of the burden
of this affirmative action stigma so it
was almost like uh uh thank you for
showing that we belong here yes perfect
boom yes that's exactly what the
situation and by the way I look I won
the only one I wasn't being
idiosyncratic
I wasn't the only one there weren't many
black people in that class but
all of us
and we laughed about it later we laughed
about it but that was there so there's
there's the stigma issue and some people
have made a lot of this some people have
really made a lot of the stigma issue my
attitude towards a stigma issue yeah
it's there it's you know again it's it's
part of
you know it's part of the situation but
I think that the benefits outweigh the
burdens but is that a burden yeah that's
a burden what are some others
um resentment
yeah resentment in society and that's a
you know so
in these in the fancy schools and by the
way you know remember when we're talking
about affirmative action
most colleges and universities in the
United States there there is no
affirmative action issue because they're
not selective hell they'll take anybody
who you know if you can pay come on in
it's only a fairly small set of schools
that are selective but of course those
are the most elite schools those are the
schools that people most want to get
into and that's one of the reasons why
we have all this you know fighting over
those schools now
um
you know there's a whole how many
millions of people
are there in America
who have applied to various places they
didn't get in
and what do they say the white person
who applied to Harvard applied to Yale
applied to Colombia
you know
apply to Georgetown
apply to NYU you could go you know
didn't get in what do they say
I would have gotten if it hadn't been
for that racial affirmative action
they're resentful well you know should
they be resentful no they shouldn't be
resentful but they are resentful does
that have a consequence yeah it has a
consequence
and as a consequence on how they act
towards other people it has a
consequence on how they vote it has a
consequence
and you know that's
that's something
um
are there other things
yeah and you know in my book I I have a
you know I go through
various
um
I think that uh I think that there is a
I think that there is a certain sort of
denialism
that has accompanied the affirmative
action
debate so
because
you know black people like myself
want to avoid
the stigmatizing burden of affirmative
action there's some people who to deal
with that
have said oh
actually
there is no difference
between
you know the beneficiaries of
affirmative action
and the other kids
there is no difference
um if if the affirmative action kids got
let's say a 500 and the other kids got a
750. uh that doesn't make any difference
that's just BS they're you know the only
reason the kid who you know the 550 kid
didn't get 750 is because the test asks
all sorts of you know biased culturally
biased things like you know what is a
yacht
mm-hmm
well
sorry uh
uh yes there is a difference
there's a 200 Point difference does the
difference matter yes the difference
matters and by the way if you don't know
what a yacht is you could know what a
yacht is without owning a yacht okay
[Music]
and there's this denialism
that I think has really seeped into
not just the you know in into various
conversations that can have a slippery
slope effect that's beyond just this yes
and you know we see it in various ways
so you know this this you know this
attack on testing
it's not like I'm holding the you know
you know some tests are not good tests I
think we should be skeptical of
everything but there are a lot of tests
that yeah they tell us something all
right they tell us who knows what
and
um there's some people who are really
you know Dead Set against testing
because they're dead set against
anything that might show a gap
well I think by the way you know are
there gaps yeah they're gaps
and what we need to do is be cognizant
of those gaps
and do things to make it so that if
there's a gap if you're if you're
deficient
no no shame in being deficient heck I'm
deficient about a lot of things
let's you know let's learn
so that I catch up
but others you know but I think
sometimes there have been people who've
been afraid
of even acknowledging
the gaps of course there's uh I guess a
colleague of yours Michael sandel with
uh with tyranny and Merit there's uh
interesting rigorous ways to kind of
challenge ways on the flip side of that
were obsessing with Merit can go wrong
also yes uh you mentioned Michael sandel
he's a a a wonderful colleague and he's
a wonderful friend I've known him a long
time I think he makes very important uh
arguments uh about meritocracy
um I disagree with uh some of the points
that he makes about you so you lean
towards the the importance of
meritocracy I think that Mary uh yes I
think that I think that there are values
in meritocracy extremely important that
in fact
you know the the the movement from you
know feudalism the movement from status
the the the the the idea of you know I
don't you know I don't care who your you
know father or mother was I don't care
from what part of town you come from I
don't care what your last name is I
don't care what your color of your skin
is
show me what you can do
and then somebody sits down okay I'll
show you what you can do you know what I
can do and they show it you're in
I think there's a lot to that and you
know the the impulse the sentiments
behind that
I'm I I resonate with that I think that
there's a lot there what I want to do is
um I want to get rid of those features
in society
that deprive people
of uh the the what you need
to develop yourself
uh you know sometimes those are
psychological
sometimes it's uh you know you're not
around people who've done things that
give you the idea that you can do things
I want to get rid of that
but the idea of
you know people
um the idea by the way of
you know distinguishing you know this is
excellent
and the people who are excellent
you know they're they're here
and then there are people who are
good
are they excellent no they're not
excellent
they're good
uh I I wanna I wanna I'm not gonna you
know close my eyes to that distinction
and uh uh highlight that distinction and
yet at the same time maintain a sense
that uh their basic worth as a human
being is equal yes so
to you know uh
was a run BMC one of the rap groups no
you know we're all written down on the
same list yeah
we're all written down on the same list
yes we're you know so I want to
recognize our fundamental Humanity
um I don't think that that I think that
one can recognize our fundamental
humanity and one can also recognize as
far as I'm concerned
that
um we all collectively should make sure
that we we do all that we can to prevent
people from sinking below a certain
level and being you know in misery I'm
you know
all for that
but I want to be careful
about
some of the attacks that I hear on
meritocracy so some of the people
including again I have all the respect
in the world for for for for for for
Michael sandeli you know talks about the
the the arrogance of the winners
okay I want to be you know I I don't
want the winners to be arrogant that's
right luck has a lot to do with things
you know you were you you didn't have
any control over the circumstances in
which you were born into you were lucky
that you were born healthy and that you
were born with a you know well working
mind you didn't have anything to do with
that that was pure luck there's some
people who don't have that luck so don't
you know you know don't be you know Mr
Big Stuff
okay
so I'm you know I'm against that sort of
arrogance you know I'm entitled as if as
if I taught myself how to read no you
didn't teach yourself how to read there
was people who did all sorts of things
for you and you don't even know it
okay so you know I want to you know get
rid of the arrogance
uh have have decent humility I'm all for
that at the same time
you know
um
I want to be careful about
the problem of Envy I want to be prob I
want to be careful about the problem of
resentment
I want to be I want to be careful about
you know I I've heard you know so let's
not have
let's not give a trophy
to the person who wins the race because
to give a trophy to the person who wins
the race will make the person who they
defeated feel bad no no no
um no I don't want that
I want to give a trophy to the person
who wins the race because I think it's a
good thing
to valorize
the best
yeah it's a it's a a kind of celebration
of
um this whole human project that we're
on yes is celebrating the best